I think we're gonna see Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross complete his comic-book
destiny and become the red Hall
character and that's how boom we get
mutants much like in the way of like
iron man ends up birthing every villain
in the Marvel Universe I think like his
his lab tinkering will birth she hopes
[Music]
we're talking about how smart Hulk got
all smart-me not bad but with me to
answer that is a bunch of very smart
people we have Eric boss because we were
supposed to have taught me back to Oh
buddy got blood poisoning so that means
ice cream producers you break the glass
if you ever guys on this episode we're
gonna talk about the Snyder cut later
actually cuz there's news about that
weirdly a few years later but first in
the ventures endgame we all saw it yes
Zack is smart in game and he's verbal
but it's sudden right he just suddenly
is is that way and we all thought that
you know between infinity war and the
Hulk loss and end game we'd get this big
explanation of what happened to Hulk in
that time and turns out nope we didn't
we just got Hulk with glasses and taking
selfies one throwaway line of he was in
the game allowed for 18 months but that
doesn't really tell us anything yeah
right but 18 months is a very long time
so here's the question and you guys are
allowed to go rogue in fact you're
encouraged to go rogue here
how did Hulk become smart
Hulk between infinity war and endgame
what did Bruce do to make himself all
smart like okay okay calm down
[Laughter]
basically my theory is that Bruce Banner
creates the equivalent of CRISPR in the
MCU and in that 18 months he develops
his own technology that allows him to
mess with his own genes
that makes him able to be Hulk and Bruce
Banner at the same time and that just
like in real life this technology is
very dangerous it's very powerful
it's very two inch tall chimpanzees
don't don't mess up my dream of one day
owning a small monkey and so it gets out
just like in real life it's that you
have to keep very very tight control of
the technology of CRISPR in the MCU
someone either steals it a bad guy like
gets a hold of a little bit or somebody
like gets experimented on and they
escape or whatever they accidentally get
exposed to the technology and that's how
boom we get mutants whoa MCU hold on
huge jump okay wait but I'm interested
in it because you're literally altering
people's genes which is what mutant like
when you make a mutation mutation what
it is how boom would that's the
connection and I'll throw out there and
in support of it gamma radiation this
meeting gene splicing certainly seems
like it could yes celebrate specifically
gamma radiation and it's this huge thing
and and it really is a metaphor for real
life because you know some scientists
have gone rogue and China using CRISPR
and it's a whole thing and so I feel
like this is a very apt very accurate
metaphor and I should be given multiple
row keys I'll give you the first one for
the mutants I think you're misusing the
word metaphor because you brought
mutants in also I'm gonna ask did Bruce
Banner do this within these 18 months
and casually just not mention it to
anyone that he has been experimenting on
people he created a race of mutant kind
well he doesn't do it intentionally
because he's a responsible scientists
yes right he says he know that he did
that he has created the technology for
himself and then after the events of
endgame an evil person or somebody
sneaks in steals it or like it's the
technologies leaked somehow somebody
puts it online
yeah I mean I think gamma radiation is
going to be the new technological
bleeding-edge thing that's studied in
phase four yeah when that's no more
stones no more guns and all that's left
of them are these traces of gamma
radiation and spread out everywhere like
yeah maybe it's not like banners crisper
in particular maybe it is maybe it's
just like the same thing that gave him
his like evolution caused evolution
among other people have these like
doormen that we've been saying though
that the snap generated so much gamma
radiation they said that in endgame that
that just altered genes all around the
world but it I like the CRISPR version
of it because it it's like the perfect
storm right like he was messing with DNA
to fix himself and then there's this
wave version of the theory - yes okay so
I have a theory that doesn't contradict
marinus theory could even be a companion
300 G's will go to marina okay so in
that diner scene where there's the kids
that want the selfie and Hulk's eating a
thousand pancakes for the ant-man and
cap and and Black Widow he says I spent
18 months in the am a lab which I loved
that he calls it the gamma lab and I
realized that I used to think that the
Hulk was the disease but that Hulk is
actually the cure oh right and that like
by melding his two personalities he
could read some kind of a better state
you know more enlightened that was his
kind of like way of grieving - for
everything that happened so I I liked
that metaphor of disease and cure and so
I think right he has he's altered his
blood maybe in a similar way to the way
Marina is talking about right through
experiments maybe it's again related to
gamma radiation he's altered the biology
of his body he's altered his blood and
this will have a future impact in that
we know we're getting a she-hulk Disney
and in the comics the origin of she-hulk
is she gets a blood transfusion she is
shot and she gets a blood transfusion
from her cousin Bruce Banner yeah and
his blood kind of almost like you know
if you get a blood transfusion from a
vampire
you become a vampire right so in the
same way it's yeah I mean it's a common
occurrence that you have to check a box
every time you do and so I think this is
all setting up right that what he has
done to change his biology will end up
affecting his cousin Jessica Walters and
she will become she-hulk because there's
been a lot of different versions of she
all can the comics just like there's
been a lot of different versions of Hulk
but like kind of the most common or the
current version of she-hulk she is
basically like smart Hulk she's a boy
she's Hulk all the time she's smart
literate while also being stupid strong
yeah and very hot yeah if if you're into
that kind of thing yeah right well and
even I I'm excited for this she-hulk
series for a lot of reasons in that you
know big part of like she looks persona
is that like her you know the kind of
masculine energy is like I want to be
big and strong so nobody can hurt me but
like a lot of like her deal was that
like she wanted to be beautiful is much
more than big and strong and so like
she-hulk is kind of the personification
of that just like the Hulk is Bruce oh
yes she's like Amazonia and she's like
very attractive besides being green so I
think he he changed his blood and that
will lead to much like in the way of
like iron man ends up birthing every
villain in the Marvel Universe I think
like his his lab tinkering will birth
she hooked I also think it kind of ties
in like mutations is a blood-borne
pathogen or something like that ties it
nice yeah we know we're getting blade
right we know we're getting vampires so
not to say that that causes vampires but
you're starting to plant those ideas of
like blood Bruce Banner the future
they're referencing a viral video for 15
years so I like this idea that Bruce
Banner has gross blood and he's just
shaking it on everybody just
transforming people left and right he's
very careful in that one he just goes
around yeah you don't want to know what
his urine does
[Laughter]
so essentially Marina's idea is the
answer to your question and then you
either sorry grosser one but it makes a
hotter person that's right yeah although
hers made all the mutants yes yeah Jean
Grey and the Eric Beavis idea I was
having for this cuz yeah I mean you
could ask yourself why now like why are
we talking about this now for one
because Hulk's future is the most
determined and MCU and he's just there
and there's so many questions we have
about him we also are wondering why did
Hulk wait to now to merge his identities
like there was a five-year gap between
you know them killing Danice at the
beginning of endgame and then what
happened after but why didn't he do any
of his research before how did it just
come to him now what had changed and I
think what had changed now is a lot of
the Avengers got either erased or they
were no longer active on earth after
after the blip notice though what we saw
after those five year at five years went
by he became a celebrity holies like now
the frontman like kids are coming up
asking for his autograph at a cool one
he's the cool one there's a deleted
scene with Dominic veljohnson where Hulk
jumps into a burning building there's a
bunch of father from family matters
die hard and they do it like kind of a
cameo as a firefighter outside with a
burning building like it was cool scam
it's a bummer that didn't make it in the
movie but it was a big hero moment for
Hulk that he never had before because
her Hulk was like kind of a jerk people
hated him because he kept breaking stuff
to where he had to leave the planet so
what I think I believe that in that
five-year period figures governmental
figures like Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross
looked to Bruce Banner as the one that
they could trust to help keep the earth
and in check because remember he doesn't
trust cap or if his friends because they
were fugitives for years Bruce banners
like he's Switzerland yeah he's a guy
that you can trust he's a smart guy
who's not Iron Man and so I think what
had happened is a Bruce banners gamma
lab was infused with government
resources that stuff that we also know I
had three technology and scroll
technology and that is what helped him
unlock his gamma radiation abilities so
that he could find this middle ground I
think what they could be setting up is
that Hulk will be the frontman of the
MCU Thunderbolts as one of these
redemptive figures who's given a second
chance to be a hero teamed up by Ross it
was some bio Thunderbolts is like a
group that existed in the Marvel Comics
it was original like baron zemo's group
and it was like him trying to create
these bad guys who pretended to be the
new avengers to fill in the gap after
the avengers all we're all done do you
say Billy Eilish well what had happened
is they all kind of turned on Zemo who's
like it was an [ __ ] and they kind of
became actual redemptive heroes Goliath
was part of them and they're actually
like a group kind of like a spin-off
Avengers and I think we're gonna see the
version of that in the MCU no longer the
Avengers they're gonna be like this
experimental group called the
Thunderbolts you might see characters
like Black Widow but killing a beloved
like what we've talked about this before
most some of these other Guardian from
the Black Widow movie oh not connect us
back to take a status
so I think speaking of Takei steadiest
[Music]
so I think where we're going is Red Hulk
I think we're gonna see
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross complete his
comic-book destiny and become the Red
Hulk character as a villain that are
gonna be set in because there's so much
hulk stuff that can happen but they
can't do it as a hulk movie they're
gonna have to backdoor it in and other
movies and other TV series you get a
silver Rogge for bringing a dog just so
you guys know I'm a future episodes you
can cheat very easy
silver Oh keys are worth 25 no I'm into
it but mostly just bringing in and if
daddy is such a funny name to me I feel
like now that Jeremy Irons is doing so
great on Watchmen William her is just
like I gotta get my corner well great
thank you yeah but mostly great dog guys
let's go play with the dog in the
meantime here's a quick message from us
hey guys Eric here just a reminder that
new rock stars is offering exclusive
rewards to our patrons in the form of
bonus videos each month for November I
did an in-depth breakdown of the opening
sequence of Raiders of the Lost Ark and
how it's so perfectly to find any Anna
Jones as a hero and foreshadow to
everything to follow in that film
including Nazis heads exploding you can
get exclusive access to that video along
with lots of other behind-the-scenes
content and just a general good feeling
of helping this channel grow have
becoming an official patron of new rock
stars Digital Studios just go to
patreon.com/scishow stars again that's
patreon.com/lenguin
and there was a wish that in a future
episode people would come dressed as
Wednesday Addams
and we can't afford Wednesday Addams
costumes or everyone so real quick as a
quick nod to that wish and who was it
that one that absolutely any so yeah
thank you so this is freed a nice piece
so the post-production team is going to
make each of us look like Wednesday
Addams for a quick second
so buddy hold still and be your best
Wednesday Addams hope they put saline in
my fingers that make rubbing my braids
yeah great
that's for you speedo all right but also
in the last week there are some tweets
and they were a seismic shift in the
events of the Warner Brothers DC
Universe because Ben Affleck and gal
gadot yeah gal gadot talk about the Ben
Affleck's Batman you guys know that and
gal gadot both tweeted they want this
night cut version of Justice League
released now all this time later yeah so
Jason Momoa has been posting about this
in general and Zack Snyder capped it all
off with retweeting all these people and
then himself once again
hashtag releases so there's a lot of
energy out of freaking nowhere about
this right now in you know 20 21 or
whatever year that were in so I don't
want to know what is going on here why
has this suddenly gained so much steam
why are people suddenly so so he's
neither could i of Justice League and
the you know director's cut of Thor dark
world I worked on well here's my theory
on this I think that the whole release
the Snyder cut movement is just that it
is a grassroots movement and I've always
felt weird weighing in on it we talked
about it when Justice League came out
because it's not like coming from the
creator's originally it's not coming
from like a Snyder it was it was from
the ground Homer initially that would be
one it was like it's essentially a
conspiracy theory not always a terrible
because I think we've seen oh Richard
Donner had a great director's cut of
Superman to Ridley Scott had a better
director's cut of Blade Runner so an
insider did have stuff from his original
cut that got cut from the film when
Whedon took over and maybe it's better
maybe it's just more but it clearly was
not finished but my theory on this is is
I think this is essentially a much much
smaller movement than the media and that
social media in particular is making it
out to be and us and us anytime we talk
about it it's like we can see our
analytics way fewer people are
interested in this topic then Twitter
would have you believe anything labor
the number the number of people the
number of people who sign this petition
was a hundred eighty thousand to release
it's not compare it to another thing a
lot of people brushed off people who
signed a petition to reshoot Game of
Thrones final season ten times the
amount of people one point eighty
million so I think I'm gonna call this
group of people the releasers because I
think it is akin 180,000 yeah and I
think it's way smaller than that oh I
think a hundred eighty thousand people
sign the petition and I think a lot of
these people just weren't crazy about
this the Justice League cut that they
saw I wouldn't be surprised if the
number is as small as a thousand people
who are on that's just a central tier
who are on these message boards were
saying we got a target these people to
try to pin between releases minor cut I
think there's a wider tier beyond that
of maybe maybe upwards of a hundred
thousand people who are just like div on
it and curious about it and then beyond
that everyone else who's just like
tweeting are just participants so the
thousand people though you think they
kind of are like you know totalling
their thumbs at work waiting to get home
to do their bidding of trying to
manipulate the system make it seem like
I think they're on Reddit I think
they're on a lake board my question is
why why are this even no matter how
small the group is why are they so hyper
motivated for this one cause I think
their motives are actually fairly pure I
think there's a lot of people who
dismiss this thing as like oh it's toxic
they just like to sabotage the Rotten
Tomatoes score Marvel films because
they're mad no I think honestly a lot of
DC fans are right to feel like a little
shortchanged because honestly DC comics
are way more they're better
I love Marvel Comics characters I love
it they MCU the Marvel Cinematic
Universe far better but like without
spider-man Marvel Comics and without
spider-man maybe without x-men like the
Avengers comics in the 70s and 80s
weren't that great like not a lot of
people really loved them until like my
guy made this great cinematic universe
DC Comics like they're so the Matic
enriched with characters they're
villains are amazing and just like
Warner hasn't been able to put together
the right formula of the movies that
have worked
Snyder has done his best Nolan did a
great job with the Dark Knight trilogy
but it just hasn't really come together
I think a lot of DC fans feel like
rightfully like a Miss you know we want
our good version of this and in their
eyes
Snyder's mysterious cut that they've
gotten hints of is like this imaginary
thing that I don't believe fully exists
that they've been able to pin their
hopes to and they think that by just
like seeing the raw untampered version
of this they can finally get and I don't
think it really exists and I think I
hope it never gets released for that
reason because I think when they see
they'll be like oh this is just like
Zack Snyder's ultimate edition of Batman
V Superman which is it's not better it's
just more of what was already there what
was already there was flawed it was
great i I don't think we have to agree
about you know the details of whether or
not Marvel or DC comics are better to
agree on just the fact that it is their
wish yeah this is the one thing stopping
them from having the dream movie that
they've wanted to have and it from what
we've seen with these films although you
know Marvel has rebooted spider-man
three times but from what you see you
only get in you're in your prime years
like you know maybe you see two solid
goes at these things and we've got our
are we already had our kind of Michael
Keaton's
all the way through about comer and we
got our Nolan Batman series and then we
got these where we have Ben Affleck and
all those things it kind of is probably
a little bit of a belief that maybe
we're not gonna get another take on this
so maybe it's it back there there is
still a great sign they're worried that
they'll never get a good one yeah I
could see that you get a rope the reason
I don't talk about is it's like it's not
a real news story it's manufactured and
I feel like if we were to talk about it
on social media it specifically used
that hashtag
we're just playing into like a small
contingency of people who are just
trying to use us to further that message
and I don't wanna be part it's not weed
it's not a real news story like how did
smart hole Kappa right yeah right this
is people are clamoring the movie that
came out and we can at least subscribe
and appreciate it I do think that's part
of it that's part of the movement but I
think who's stoking the flames Zack
Snyder as we've talked about okay he's
teased fans like a still image from a
shot that he did and never made it in
the final and like he's obviously like
encouraging people like Jason Momoa to
keep this going by like showing them
clips and stuff like that I think
secretly Zack Snyder does not want the
Snyder cup I think the Snyder cut is
more powerful to Zack Snyder as an idea
this is a film I think he's using this
specifically because like he worked his
way up through movies like 300 and
whatever and Dawn of the Dead remake
Watchmen right into that top tier of
people that can afford to can get a
Batman movie right yeah there's not a
lot of people that are at that level and
so and now I think he feels like he's
been knocked down he had a kind of a
rough streak Man of Steel Batman V
Superman Justice League a lot of people
were disappointed by those and kind of
his general vision for DC so I think
this is his way of being like no no
those weren't disappointments I was held
back right it's not my if you didn't
like any of those movies it wasn't my
fault
this was the higher-ups and the
muckety-mucks if keeping me from being
able to realize my full vision yes Logan
Paul right now saying that I didn't
actually lose that fight against ksi it
was because of this basically
the ref made a mistake and he said what
kind of man would I be if I didn't stand
up for what I believe in that I actually
won that fight it's the same thing of
just like like standing up against the
man is only because they're the ones
that made it yes and I think like
there's something there's this movement
especially among like a certain type of
filmmaker who has like a very nerdy fan
base and I'm thinking of like Kevin
Smith who's like you know had kind of
not quite the CE mark is as Zack Snyder
they're totally different genres like
comedy versus like action but like Kevin
Smith now has realized that like as his
market has shrunken it's he's never
gonna have a billion dollar movie but he
can have these smaller movies with super
passionate fan base yeah and so I think
this is ex Nider being like I see the
future I don't need ten million people
to love my movies I want a hundred
thousand that'll ride or die with me
kind of thing yeah yeah yang gang I'm
just gonna get these people to be
obsessive about me yes I will throw your
way that there's precedent for how
people feel about James Gunn now post
all that drama where they're like oh
we're not gonna get the James Gunn
version of this movie and then he used
that and you know negotiated Suicide
Squad - yeah and now suddenly we are
kind of excited about Suicide Squad -
and then he's back on Marvel properties
and now we're like triple e excited and
then everybody became at James Gunn's
stand some because it felt like he had
been wrong and Zack Snyder's on the
sidelines like whoa wait hold on we can
do that yeah there's something to be
said for that right like we love it when
like an actor off screen has a narrative
arc Robert Downey jr. yeah Iron Man was
redemptive for him as a person right
maybe maybe there's a little bit of that
we want that for a director too you know
we that's kind of like mi has had a
little bit of a resurgence you know he's
like he has like part of that was like
he could've had that same arc of like
huge director one of the top in
Hollywood he had just kind of like a
series of like worsening movies gets
totally in the doghouse and then like
Kenny comes back with some new kind of
smaller films and people like whoa I
kind of like Emma Knight again
I wonder if that's the Zack Snyder being
like that's the writing on the wall
so Eric's idea is that the movement
doesn't really exist exist
Zacks is that the cut doesn't really
exist marina this whole conspiracy the
the fandom doesn't exist none of this
actually exists it's just the studio oh
that's really sobering I forgot to give
a
Rogi to Zack for his so you think Warner
and he's what yeah yeah because uh there
because gal gadot tweeted or gadot right
Ben Affleck tweeted or a flock and you
have to like have some influence to get
them to tweet wasn't it on the same day
yeah it was a day after my mother I
think to you they were all like oh the
court a coordinated effort you have to
get so many things to their attention
like somebody what their publicist were
like hey you gonna tweet this today
right and it's all for I think they're I
think they actually are going to release
it but they're gonna release it on HBO
max only cost twenty freaking dollars I
believe but maybe they reduce the price
I think it's gonna be the most expensive
yeah I think it's like sixteen or so
just a quick reminder that we already
pay for HBO and that's not what we're
talking about this is additional twenty
twenty-one
HBO max the Warner Brothers I've heard
of streaming sure and even if they got
they hunt those hundred eighty thousand
you know people it's like a sign-up like
I didn't sign the petition but like if I
was had enough like you know gumption to
be like I'm gonna sign this petition
it's like well I really want to see that
cut yeah hey you know if it does exist I
want to see it I'll watch more than I
watch every deleted scene of every movie
we've talked about I'm just curious and
curiosity I like it but sticking with
this idea this is all a marketing ploy
for the release of HBO max
years in the making that's if they're
pulling that off that's incredible
pretty brilliant if I mean Studios are
about making money if you think they're
not doing their due diligence and their
research on like social media and social
media and how to use it to make money
like get out of here like of course it's
literally someone's job to do this kind
of thing the argument in your favor it
is an open secret in this town that the
whole stupid Netflix Bird box phenomenon
the bird box challenge
completely manufactured by Netflix
nobody was doing the bird book challenge
especially considering nobody had seen
it yeah came out and it was like oh god
I did they do it well always didn't know
that yeah but there were a hundred
articles written about it by more like
don't let your kids do it yeah kind of
free publicity bird box was the
most-watched film Thanksgiving yeah it's
easy to cherry-pick anecdotal social
media posts and call it a movement yeah
but numbers don't lie and like we're in
the business like so much of our
business here on new rockstars is
looking at the numbers of things looking
at what is really trending yeah and the
Snider cut has never trended and
compared to anything else we've talked
about I think it is smaller control by
like a studio side or it's a small
contingency of like 100 people in
Macedonia it's not a real story in
backing up marinas argument I mean it
does seem like maybe DC Warner has kind
of figured some stuff out only in that
like the press ahead of the Robert
Pattinson the Batman yeah he's like kind
of good yeah this is really positive
they're coming off a Joker that was kind
of their best receiving movie in a while
maybe they have kind of cracked the code
a little bit cuz I think that's
something that affected Snyder's DC
movies I don't didn't feel like they had
quite the buzz that a lot of the MCU
know these can generate ahead of their
release week and everybody's dying to
see the trailer and stuff like yeah well
do you know one of the biggest reasons
why Joker has such positive reviews not
just it's a it's an fine film and and
there's plenty of reasons to like it but
one of the reasons why people are
obsessed with it is because of the drama
of other people saying that it went too
far
and it shouldn't be allowed to be shown
to kids so you know as the passions get
risen I mean this is why we have the the
bipartisan issues or the lack of that in
our country is because everything was
pushed as in everything's life or death
so you better be a hundred percent of
everything of what's human you have to
have an opinion on it
you can't even disagree with your own
party right so if you're a DC stand now
like yeah and there's DC drama and
they're hiding the Snider cut for some
reason like now here's the thing I'm
gonna put one Rogie on the line up here
but we're gonna make this democratic cuz
I actually liked all of these answers so
Marina basically is saying that the
studios are behind the single whole time
Zack is saying that basically Zack
Snyder and maybe his publicist or people
you all can read each other's minds be
share one brain eric is saying that it's
a couple of motivated fans are clever
enough to make it seem like the much
bigger movement you guys vote on which
seems the most likely between the three
of us yeah I mean I think there's a
little bit I'm actually this this is not
doing us any favors I think it's a
combination of the two things I think
it's a studio they're recognized a small
minority and you're like let's
capitalize on this can only vote for
one's okay it began over here crackpot
corner with the with the grassroots
thing recognize this movement and used
it for his own purposes the studio is
now capitalizing off it it's all
possible but I think if one of us has to
be most rate I think marinas probably
clear alright I'm gonna give one to
marina and then actually one to Eric
they tie them all together in a way
didn't work yak maybe if you if you had
brought all of them the squeeks guys
it's time for rogue questions it could
throw these point totals all over the
place but as a quick update marina has
three zach has two and eric has no okay
so these are questions that I have not
seen you guys haven't either
and will reward some points Adam driver
said in an interview this week that he
kept a lot of the props from the rise of
Skywalker set what's the weirdest thing
Adam driver is doing at home with his
lightsaber I've always dreamt of like
you know they have like blenders that
also heat soup I think I mean what
better way to stir a suit yeah I didn't
know you were this body hair zippers are
real only above the belly button juris
what am I gonna bleep and that kids won
cuz it's almost good
Eric gets a little baby one because I
think the image is one of the quarter
all right next question
parasite I've seen this and snowpiercer
director bong Joon who ho-ho says he'll
never direct a superhero you Brooker ik
a superhero movie because he hates to
see people wearing tight clothing what
other kind of weird stupid phobia could
keep you from liking a superhero movie
that's great well definitely if you have
a phobia against white people when every
Marvel character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe shows up on screen at the same
time and the minorities are aliens this
week that it costs 5 million dollars oh
my god to fix the Sonic the Hedgehog
design 5 million dollars you'd rather a
go toward toward that they like it is he
for less than I thought they would spend
I think is like yeah the movie me
because you guys what terrible VFX movie
would they have to pay you 5 million
dollars to watch anything for $5 bad VFX
here I really hate like anytime they do
a human face oh yeah uncanny valley i
gotta say it's it would be very hard for
me to rewatch the Matrix sequels oh yeah
I don't know if I need 5 million but I
need those wins I need at least $55
yeah some of those shots with agent
Smith were pretty well done
but the rubbery movement when they were
fighting is pretty tough there's a very
small there's like four two people but
there's like a very there's one episode
and The Walking Dead I think it's II was
at season seven where they have a deer a
CG idea oh yes
and it was like made fun of all over the
internet because it would just looked
crazy and then also the tiger is like
not great in that but for free what's
yours Phillips I probably just that the
baby that looks like the bad design
sonic in the Twilight movies vampire
blow so everybody looks creepy in that
movie can we all acknowledge that
everybody has like a weird wig so let's
see where we ended up remember our
winner will get their wish granted the
other twos will get the opposite of
their wish has to happen to them so
marina how many got four so four but
mine are taller than him Eric it looks
like 27 points or or 4.2 4.25 whose line
the points do matter so you're gone
is that keep speaking your normal voice
from now on Eric everyone must work
McClung key into their sentences as much
as possible
that's among key of this funky thanks
for going McConkey with us I thanks so
much who are McClung Keys marina you can
find my own McClung key at McClung key
masters on twitter McClung key clunks
don't
McClung key follow me on any social
medias I'd never tweet or post so it's
not my clunky worth it
what's something with your McClung key
spend afternoon you can find me McClung
key we're doing McClung key of McClung
key and mac and a lung key but not lucky
we got an Empire Strikes Back breakdown
we're continuing star wars rewatched
series we're gonna be doing some more
analyses of these McClung key endgame
deleted scenes and Rick and Morty season
4 has been great so far yes lucky more
that yeah all right
[Laughter]
[Music]